所有的皮膚問題里面我最不擔心的就是長豆和長壁口
因為我能讓他們在七天內就從我的臉上消失
我的臉上是長過幾千克豆豆
所以對於怎麼快速解決他們
我已經非常得心應手了
今天我就把這七天的一個戰鬥方法手把手的分享給你們
第一天就是先要去做真情這個很重要
真情可以加速豆豆和壁口的擔心中期
你們看我臉上的戰鬥豆
他們就是這種不貌白頭的紅種豆
你不去真情去干預他們
他們就可以在那臉上留一個圓
就算平了豆根也還在裡面
後續還是會長
然後留下的那種豆腐又深入難銷
但是如果長一個好的真情氣時
當長情玩你的豆當長就平
因為氣勢他可以把那個豆根給清出來
你就不會讓你反腐長
豆腐也會淡得
比你讓他自己爆出來要快很多
那大部分的必口
清完之後也會直升下一個小紅點
好的豬肉變快不容易留豆腐
果然如果是等必口自己去戴線
變成紅種豆腐
豆腐也又是很深很紅的那種
清完就要進士馬上給你們
吐上這個方式
清過的地方
八火加快口的變好
六個小時之後
就可以正常的洗臉護服了
但是前三天的護服很關鍵
他決定了你豆腐清痛的快慢
那如果不知道怎麼護服的結明
你們就直接操作業
然後我一般真清完的前三天
都不會化妝業
不會吐防剩少
然後清完的當天晚上
不要用自來水洗臉
就用這種身類圓水配合面片清清的
擦試乾淨就好
然後就可以用一些
劑清爽
用部門豆企修護力強的護護力
就是我實驗下來之後
真清完我喜歡
用這一套用自己的圖
就是安角完成
加三十五點馬加四九面爽
過完輔之後
再在臉上的頭子上
再圖這個臉上
第二天早上起床
我也還是會用身臉的水
繼續踏實貼服
但是到第二天晚上
就會增長的臉
面合就會用一些腳溫和不刺激的洗臉奶
然後前三天早晚的話
就可以一繼續這樣子護服
你會發現你的臉上
動應就是一天比以前淡的
因為你剛剛真清完
你就去用這種
淡化豆腐的東西去干預它
它的豆腐就是比你平時
自己要爆出來要好得快很多
那在第四天之後
可以根據自己皮膚
恢復的情況和你的耐受程度
再跟之前一樣的
晚間護服之前先用一個水洋酸動物
如果第四天
你臉上口咱沒有恢復好了
這一步也就往後落
但是你一定要在後面的護服裡面
用上水洋酸
因為你容易長豆腐
比方就是毛孔有一肚子
水洋酸它就像在
皮膚線裝了一個髮人的養
可以控制檢照皮膚的車子
還能一直豆腐塗毛孔
但現在老實講吃
這樣才能夠真正的減少
豆豆和皮孔身長
用酸的晚間護服控制
就是晚上洗完臉之後
先用一個你可以耐受的水洋酸動物
在臉上副個5-10分鐘
副完洗乾淨之後
再接著用前三天的護服控制
可是按兩門雖然加安三宣宣家浮的時候
你們專家要服服就好
給大家聽一個總結圖
能可以直接按照這個
早晚護服流程來做
就不出期限你的臉
也可以跟我一樣
可以去當這種光滑系列的狀態
大家如果做的話記得來做我反規